Hoang, thì là mặt hàng mọi người được nắm rất, thì nâng nước không quinh thích.
Cái khúc tạo là giá trị ra tăng cho nên tình tế đặc biệt trong bố cảnh chúng ta đang phải huy động.
Một lực rất lớn, cho đồ tư phát triển tình tế sau.
Sau nên chúng ta phải hạnh chế tôi đã kẹp biệt, tâm lý gâm rất và tâm lý đầu cơ.
Tếu chúng ta có được nguyên tạng, vì mô vấn trạng.
Một kẻ thống pháp lý, tôm 2, mình bàn rế rửa bảo.
Người rất và tăng nhập in tâm.
Tìa không nắm rất là tài sản đó, ím tâm bỏ tiền ra, ní là mại quá n khuy cùng.
Tì chúng ta mới vi động được một lực.
Có nếu là tài sản, người ra nguyên tạng màu của anh tài sản, chúng ta không để cân thiệp được bảo điều này.
Nguyên chúng ta có thể có cơ chế và có những cái biện pháp của thẻ, về điều hành chính phát để vi động được một lực.
Tình phải có những cái biện pháp để có lý chất chẽ.
Tất kêu vật động này, không có lý gây đến, chế mỏng và tệ làm xú dạm, vự chứng ngoại hồi rửa bất ổn bị mô ra tăng lạm phát.
Rồi, kích hoạt tệ tâm lý đầu cơ và mả tệ tài sản vui đó không.